Okay,
we are live here.
Hello.
Let me set the title of this and then I
will switch the uh the screen over real
quick.
It's been a while. I think I haven't
streamed in like what a week, a little
longer.
Uh let's just grab
category
Yeah, we're good.
Oops, that's the puffer
there.
Hey, Jess.
So,
uh what has gone on in the last week?
So, first of all, we had a uh sort of
rush order client job.
Um where some of the work for that I
wasn't able to stream. some of that was
private
and uh then thereafter,
you know, I don't know. I think that
thereafter there was a bunch of fiddly
experimental work and just a bunch of
like really annoying refactor stuff that
wasn't particularly interesting and
where streaming would not really bring
anything.
Um things are relatively stable now. I
have a little bit of time this week to
be working on the core code base.
So, uh I'm going to go over very quickly
what we have from this.
Here we have a experimental branch of
Puffer with everything in CUDA and C.
It's quite a mess. This is already after
a few phases of refactoring.
It's quite a mess. It has nearly three
times as many files as there should be.
Um, a few thousand lines more code than
there should be,
but this is including the protein port.
This includes constellation. This
includes the pufferet CPU version. This
includes all the new selfplay stuff.
And it's under 14K lines.
So, what I'd like to basically do is
figure out how to get this cleaned up.
Fewer files, fewer things jumping all
over the place, fewer lines.
Um,
we'll want a couple of tests for this.
Not very many, just a couple overall
things with it.
And, uh, yeah, we'll go from there.
Um, I think just the historical selfplay
is mostly stable, but that it doesn't
guarantee that you're going to
generalize well to held out policies.
Okay, so
let's think what we do next.
I just uh pulled in the changes from the
latest protein PR
I haven't actually looked at the protein
stuff cuz I think it was very heavily AI
gen um though with a lot of manual
cleanup. I'm going to
see if we can get a couple files merged
first before I really get into too much
detail. Do we still use puffer train or
do we use puffer sweep? Buffer train is
still the correct thing for individual
runs.
This is also just I'm not saying that
it's stable on this branch, right? This
is a new branch. We're testing stuff
here.
Of course, we're not going to just take
this thing's advice.
Okay, that's a lot of indirection and
jankiness, isn't it?
Yeah. Okay. There's definitely stuff to
clean up in here. Um, I would say the uh
the code for this does not look great to
me at all.
So, I think I'm not going to care too
much about messing things up because
it's already not amazing.
So, um, Glitzy on the Discord submitted
this and already to his credit cleaned
up like 700 lines of it. It's obviously
we can save a lot more. So, let's just
remove two files real quick and see if
this gets us a few lines.
What I'm doing here for reference Oh, I
should also update this title.
Um
and certitation
I don't know mcking through sewage
that sounds about All right.
Well, it's very annoying. Like, I don't
think people realize how much that like
this shitty stuff makes you dependent on
it. It's not like, "Oh, the AI gen some
code. Now, let me go edit it manually.
Now, the AI has generated so much code
and it's so bad that it'll take you
forever to get it like done manually
from there. You know, it's way way
slower to edit AI gen code than it is to
edit like well handwritten code, like
good handwritten code. So, you end up
having to at least get it into roughly
the right shape for you to be able to
handedit it.
Like I don't even know why this was even
there.
Also, all the colonel launch checks are
gross.
My goal for this is roughly 10 files of
roughly 1 to 2,000 lines each.
Like in my mind, the ideal structure is
a relatively small number of relatively
large files.
I think there's an argument to be made
for even just sticking everything in a
file.
We're not going to quite do that, but
Jess, it literally doesn't matter what I
say because it's not just idiocy, it's
willful idiocy. Like even if I come up
with like a hey, you know, experienced,
been doing this for 20 years nearly.
[ __ ] I actually almost have been doing
this for 20 years. Um,
like even if I show like very clearly,
they're going to be like, "Oh, skill
issue. You need to use sub agents or
whatever the fuck." Like it's not worth
it. I don't I have better things to do
than try to convince idiots,
you know,
like the point of what I do. This is not
an education stream and it's not an
entertainment stream. It ends up being a
um education stream some of the time,
but this is primarily just we're going
to advance the field. like this is just
research done live
and um
I don't really need to just like be
putting out content that takes my time
for the sake of it.
It's way way more important to me right
now that I am able to like get this into
roughly the right shape in the quickest
way possible
so that we can continue to like build on
our core methods because the selfplay
stuff, the reason I did this now is the
selfplay added so much shitty Python. It
was just all right, that's too much. I
no longer have any idea what the hell's
going on and um it's just we can't just
have this language barrier anymore.
Yeah, just it's very bad. Honestly, I
like the most productive thing you can
do is not try to fight it. Not even not
engage with it at all. Just ignore all
of it
and just like, you know, learn real
stuff. Do good work. That's it.
Because the progress we've had in just
the last few months has been nuts. I
mean with 40
we're getting good progress on a number
of different hard benchmarks internally
now 5 the main problem was we couldn't
even find reasonably posed problems that
needed an algorithmic change and yeah I
stopped on it for a bit because we had
to rep prioritize a few things but I
mean now we have essentially a good
chunk of five and a good chunk of six
already
I can put up with that, Jess. It's just
don't open Just don't open the internet.
It's easy.
I'm looking for what else we can move.
So, this puffer vcash thing was just
from a side project. I'll keep it there
for now, but it'll be out eventually.
These look like nice units.
These less so.
it. The funny thing just as I thought we
were going to have to do that, it
literally does it for you. Like puffer
just adjust to the end speed. So if your
end is slower, it just finds more data
efficient solutions. I think honestly
the um the bigger thing with the
hyperparameter sweep is actually just
understanding a few of the
hyperparameters that are often set
unintuitively.
Um, like the really low clip
coefficients and stuff. There's some
oddity there. Hello, Arch.
Welcome.
I like this file now.
I like this file.
I think I even like the loss file the
way it is.
This is just doing like manual
hierarchical elomerative clustering
basically.
Hey FBR
breakout solve 10x
confused end of stepping.
What is 10x faster? What is this wall
clock solve that you got?
Cuz you don't have 10x overhead from the
end.
You can very easily get like plus
20 10 to 20% on breakout
um by porting it to the GPU, but there's
really no point.
It just like kind of complicates one of
the simple demo ends.
I'm just looking here if what we can
merge.
Oh, actually this would be a good
question.
Budaport
uh among other things. Yes. Arch. So
here we have
proteins 1400 lines from the PR
and then GP is 784 lines.
buffer box is available.
Uh yeah, I'll ask whenever you see
Spencer.
Speaking of which, I got to make sure
that I have um let me make sure that I'm
not
dropping his box.
>> Yeah, of course, Jess. I I don't know
actually. I'll ask Spencer what he's
doing with it at the moment. Um, I think
he's mostly
We're using the vast box at the moment.
If he's done with it though, I also
might want to let Finn use it for net
hack.
I get the sense he feels bad about the
vast bill otherwise.
Uh
that's what it's the computer is for,
right? Is for their experiments.
Intern. Yeah. B's been doing good stuff
already.
I know. I kind of just approached like,
yeah, do whatever you want. Learn some
stuff. I mean, I'm sure that he's like
all the stuff he's doing is going to be
super useful.
Hey Val,
how's it going? Man,
I've been meaning to chat with you about
the um the ends you've been working on
for a while. Like you have all this
awesome stuff and I just haven't gotten
to looking at them in a while.
Inferno plus colom are going to be so
nice. We actually really actively need
like hard like hard but they have to be
clean, right? like clean but hard test
MS. Um
cuz we got to make sure everything works
when I do this whole C port
and then we're going to need tests for
puffer 5
cuz I want to do something with state
sets but like if it doesn't help on hard
ends
one we have to figure out why but I
don't want to like just merge in new
algorithm stuff that doesn't actually
help like we have enough of that
[ __ ] in the field already.
I would think colo would be so much
easier than inferno.
You can get 50 mil steps solved. They're
usually a bit slower though from what
I've seen.
16 to 17 mil is good, especially if
that's not on a top-end GPU.
If you actually can tell me like what
you changed specifically, you know, to
integrate Okay.
3080 Ti. Okay, that is very good PF. Um,
I do need to know like
I need like some actionable stuff
though, right? Like I need a set of
changes to implement that actually gave
you speed with some measurements, not
like here's a massive diff from codeex
or whatever, right?
Okay, for a bot, I guess you're somewhat
right, Volo.
I guess I didn't consider it that bad
because it only took it took me like a
day and a half from just coming back to
the game to get my quiver. Inferno felt
much harder,
but I probably used a very different
strategy. Okay.
Well, you I you probably have a gear
edge as as well. I mean, I literally
just brought uh Bull Work and Justy. I
was like, "All right, I will say Volo,
the one thing is um it probably doesn't
know the start tile."
Like, it probably doesn't know what tile
to start on, and that's a major thing.
How to start RL blogs on my um the
articles on my X account, x.com/juarez,
and just click my articles tab.
Hey, Liberty
Yeah, I mean there's a huge number of
things that we can definitely do in
Puffer. Um,
I haven't done like a big round of Perf
optimization in a while, but we there's
so much other stuff to do at the moment.
Getting rid of Python in my mind is
going to be so nice. Like all our all of
our annoyances and user bugs and things,
they all come from Python being a piece
of crap.
double engine.
Uh the one that's currently in puffer.
No idea.
Yeah. See, this is just a big mess.
Happy fourth. Have you had some
margaritas? One or two.
See, like this. Look what crept in. This
is just so garbage.
Keep in mind I'm not attached to any of
this at all because this is all just
this is all just considered crap at the
moment. This sweep file
um this has not been cleaned at all yet.
Ideally, bits of this will get glued
closer to protein. Bits of it will get
cleaned up. And uh it'll get close
enough that I can start actually looking
at what the hell's going on here.
Like this stupid thing, right? This
doesn't need to be here. None of this
needs to be here.
Like why is it like what on earth is it
doing here? Right? This is just blleh
bad.
So if we can shave like a couple hundred
lines off of sweeps between merging and
just like unfucking this file,
then that gives that puts I'd say sweeps
in a much better spot overall. There's
way too much boiler plate and glue here.
I don't even want to know what this is.
Let's get rid of it. And then I think
all of like the logging dashboard
checkpoint. Like there are a lot of
these little files that can probably get
merged.
That'll be next.
We do have a few things that I'm not
super happy with. Like the fact that we
have this separate kernel CU file.
Like I don't know why I did this.
And then we also have a lot of these
little things that kind of make sense as
standalones.
Um I just I don't like having all these
little tiny files. I don't know. Maybe
that's just too pedantic but or too not
even pedantic. That's the wrong word.
Like this might be just too obsessive in
some sense, but like seeing all these
little tiny like BF-16 file that's only
40 lines, precision file that's 58 lines
that probably has this in it, right?
like
100line table files, 22 line puffer end
file, 94 line, like just all these
little tiny scattered bits annoy me.
We do have the old size. So this is 507
lines.
We have size before and after.
We don't care what test files it makes.
Um we're not going to maintain any of
those. It can just do whatever with
that.
We don't do those types of tests.
We mostly do Perf tests and then um
like integration.
Okay, it's hard coding all of this,
which is really jank.
Okay, it's shorter, but there's a mess.
Why is this all
Interestingly, it's not in here.
H.
Oh, okay. Actually, this is fine. That's
just the test file.
So, this thing is still bad.
This sweep crate here.
Weird.
What? Cuda
like 13. I think 13 or 13.1
in newer versions, but changes are 13.
How on earth are you using stuff that
matters that much on the CUDA version?
Like base CUDA doesn't change that much,
right? Version to version. It's mostly
the libraries on it.
Immediately refused.
Yeah, Valo, I no longer give them money.
I'm very happy to just help them
speedrun bankruptcy any%.
Yeah, it's the most like it's the most
out of touch company in existence.
Least substantial one.
They've literally been that way from day
one as well. It's not like a surprise or
anything.
noticed that I dropped I dropped um
uh Claude like months before they did
this. just like figuring like I'm sick
of giving these idiots money.
some stuff that only works on certain
versions. Do you have an example? Like I
can't think of a single thing that you
could have included that would have been
version dependent.
Yeah, this actually did make it a little
tiny bit shorter. Not significantly, but
we'll be able to do that Next.
I would like to move
this up maybe.
We have all this selfplay stuff in
leagues. It's annoying. And train work.
I'm trying to think if we want to move
validation up or not.
Is it in config right now?
Puffer 5 is going to come out well
before this year is over. Um, it might
end up getting switched so that most of
what was planned for puffer six is
actually puffer five and most of what
was planned for puffer five is puffer
six. I don't know. The whole selfplay
thing is kind of thrown a wrench into
this frankly
longer total train steps
to save.
Uh, yeah. So crit, this is a a big
annoyance is if you take a a fixed
config and just run it for longer, you
can do worse because of the learning
rate scheduler. I have not been able to
get schedule free to work. If anybody
wants like a um reasonably complex like
but well-contained research task, if you
can actually get schedule free to work,
and you have to have this tested on a
bunch of M's to confirm it, but if you
can get schedule free to work, it would
be a very large contribution to Puffer
for that reason. Like, we would like to
be able to just run [ __ ] for longer and
have it work.
You guys see why I have this title as
mcking through sewage? Like,
it's just such a mess.
like the problem is that if you
prototype stuff in Python first like you
don't just port the Python to C and then
be done the structure that like the
clean structure ends up being
fundamentally different
any ends recommend to test things on
working. Yep. Uh Puffer 4 would be the
stable branch.
I just tried something quickly and I
didn't see anything work. Um obviously
match breakout speedrun.
Um we'd want to see at least like one of
the longer running ends like probably
mazes are good 2048. If I saw breakout
mazes in 2048 all working, I'd merge it
from that.
You'd also obviously you'd want to test
like you know getting the sweep result
that matches
the current sweep result or is better
and then you run it for longer and it
keeps improving or whatever.
How did it just add a 100 lines of code?
Piece of [ __ ]
Now the the base CUDA API is very very
minimal.
I mean that's more of a language than an
API almost. I mean, I guess they change
a few things here and there, but it's
mostly the uh the libraries that depend
on CUDA,
like their higher level stuff that
changes a bunch.
That's fun. Is that a scammer or is that
a real
invite?
I will uh
I will test that out.
Isn't that the thing that Elon always
wanted to do from back in the PayPal
days was to have a like a financial
transactions app called X? We just
bought Twitter and then added it to that
and renamed it.
That's good. I don't think we have like
a specific backwards compatibility
target for um for CUDA as much as we
have like a well probably that shouldn't
break because we don't really use any of
the more niche fancy things that change
often anyways.
It just added 100 lines of validation
for absolutely no reason.
I am actually very happy though that
we're going to get rid of the like um a
little bit of Python overhead on
startup.
if anything, wouldn't you just play with
the coup blast settings?
We don't have any like
fancy operations that would need custom
tiling. It's literally just map moles,
Still a mess.
Okay, that's minus some, but we need to
get was it 580 it was before.
This is still 40 lines of crap up.
which part of puffer is still Python
with this nothing
in um before this port in the current
40.
There is like a launcher that also
handles the multiGPU wrapper and config
parsing and command line args
few other things that's in Python and
then protein is the big thing that was
in Python.
I mean like the dashboards in P there's
like lots of little things right that
were in Python.
This is going to be very nice because
you just won't even need to have Python
at
Oh, wait. Wrong file. Wait. Is it
uh
Yeah, this is one of the actual like
ones that makes some sense.
The shorter
Yeah, that's shorter. Okay, let's see
what else there is in
God damn.
Thing just cannot help introducing
garbage.
Like this is unfortunately still faster
than me doing it manually, but hell is
this dumb.
Like the last pass is of course going to
still end up having to be manual.
But Jesus, like look at this, right?
Trivially dupes a uh
dupes the hardcoded
validation check.
This isn't a CUDA boot camp, Jess. This
is like a not being [ __ ] boot camp.
I mean this is just like basic
keep it simple don't abstract or
duplicate.
Uh this is this has nothing so the speed
at which I can edit this has nothing to
do with CUDA. This has more to do with
the original structure in Python not
mapping one to one with the C.
And
it mostly has to do with a huge amount
of structural change all having to
happen at once.
I was going to say usually people say
like yikes when you drop a slur by
mistake.
I mean once you really and I mean once
you really see the extent to which the
whole
overarching idea behind Python is just
bad for stuff like this.
I mean, obviously like a lot of this
stuff is bad as well,
but I mean, like, do you see what I see?
I mean, when it's like roughly the right
shape is what I say. It's like, yeah,
these stupid helpers up here, this is
like garbage, right? But then look,
we've got one big validation function.
got one place where we parse the
the config into a into a strruct.
There's some questionable stuff here,
but not that much of it.
And that's it.
Okay, there you go. Now it's actually
the desired length. Good.
Yeah, we should just canonicalize this
into uh
I mean, do you see sort of just like the
the give and take here though?
We should also this should go into
config.
Unfortunately, there's still enough
stuff in here that it seems unlikely
we'll be able to remove this uh this
entire file.
Okay, there's a lot more to do here, but
sweep is now down to 410 lines.
Does it need to be guarded?
Precision T.
All right.
Uh,
yeah. So, this is stale. Good.
So, this gets cleaned up a little bit.
Presumably, we can merge some of this
stuff. Actually, there's no reason this
can't just go into um kernels or
something.
Yeah, there you go. That's actually way
easier.
And then that would be minus 19 lines
and minus a file, which would be really
nice.
Mhm.
We don't need eight dims either for our
tensors. We can probably reduce this to
what we actually use.
Um I think actually yeah, we did make it
so ve no longer depends on this, right?
That's why we originally had this mess.
But yeah, Ve doesn't need um Vec really
doesn't need access to these tensors.
It's quite simple to do without it.
Okay, that's minus a file
and minus some code.
can include this I believe
with the puffer end API.
BF16. I don't think we use this
actually, do we?
Maybe we do.
cuz I think you do need it for that. And
I think that's the only place you need
it.
I don't actually know whether this will
be needed by um we might need this in
our model or whatever,
I think that this is fine to just have
here.
And we're down to 13531.
And how many files here
What are we doing? We are refactoring
this CNCUDA port
of uh puffer. I guess this pop for 4.5
maybe five
let me get this authenticated ated real
quick. Whoops.
Ignore that in the background.
Put some changes.
not remember some of the things I Okay.
Uh, let me take a quick look.
Let me take a quick look.
Some flows can be converted to ins.
The min group can be optimized to store
values in registers
depending on how big the buffers are.
You don't need to have separate
sequential steps.
Generate all M's in parallel.
Wait,
cutting out with the CUDA port for
breakout. Yeah. So obviously with the
CUDA port for breakout.
Yeah, you you obviously you can cut out
the copy.
But wait, how on earth does that get
you?
Oh, cuz you had 47% time on eval.
I see. Cuz almost all the time was on
Eval
for your I wonder what does mine Oh,
actually, yeah, mine would work exactly
the same way as yours.
But the thing is, I don't know if this
is
I wonder if it's single buffered is
faster. No, it's not.
Huh.
I'm honestly surprised there is that
much overhead still even on a low-end
system.
So yeah, with this setup, I guess it
makes sense.
Presumably the CPU was just getting
hammered somehow,
even though the end should be um very
fast.
Do you remember how much you got off of
Mingru?
I frankly I have no idea why the uh this
CPU gets hammered as hard as it does. It
really shouldn't. It should be very
lightweight on CPU.
I mean, you can also open a PR with it.
Like, I won't merge the PR obviously if
it just has a bunch of random stuff, but
I might go like pick stuff out of it,
you know?
All right, let's see what we can do next
here.
uh yeah, NSIS is good. Actually, we have
the um if you just grab the profile
kernel script, the profile kernel script
already is built for that. Like you can
run that with NSIS.
Okay, let's see which of these files we
can realistically think about merging,
right?
Like we have too many of these stupid
little files.
Like this shouldn't even exist, should
it?
I mean, realistically,
how many of the these do I know for sure
are good?
One.
4 5
8 9
Okay, so there are actually only 10
files.
that I know that I'm happy exist in
here.
I don't know where the rest of the [ __ ]
should go, though.
It's probably the interface on models
that screwy. Frankly,
there's just a whole bunch of random
gross stuff.
Oh, well, there it is. I think a lot of
the logging stuff
We can merge
eval with pufferet. Maybe
Yeah, we can definitely get this to be
merged cleanly.
Huh?
Okay. I don't know what the heck.
Oh, and Oops. I sent to the background
process.
aside from merging in.
I think that's fine. Honestly,
we just get rid of the dead stuff.
Keeping Puffernet on its own is kind of
nice though.
if it's not obvious. Um,
the reason that I very strongly prefer
having as few files as possible is you
just get lost very very easily when
there are a ton of different files
unless it's like a very very obvious
standalone unit. Like it's kind of fine
to have a small file for muon. Um, it's
kind of fine to have like a loss file
like a loss function just for this one
big kernel.
That's kind of fine. But when you start
like breaking up structural stuff into
lots of different files,
it gets very easy to get lost. So that
doesn't mean that like it's always
better to have the fewest files
possible, but it's it's kind of like
lines of code. It's a very strong signal
cache data and constellation I think is
going to be Next.
We'll have to figure out some other
thing to do that's not the um tnape for
the third plot.
We'll probably make some nice changes to
constellation as well. Anyways,
yeah. I honestly there's probably we can
there's probably better stuff we can
replace that with.
So now we do have to still clean up
cache data and the table code at the top
of constellation.
But this is like very quickly getting to
be smaller. So, because we did all those
other refactors before, now we get to
cut some files down.
And then we'll think about what else we
can break up.
21 files.
I think we started with like 30
Uh there's it's not that like I can nick
it's just there's no reasonable way to
do that at all. Yes.
Yeah. 24. I mean, I could think about
it, Jess, but like
yeah, there's because of the
pre-processing and stuff we do, it's
like a fundamentally batch operation.
GH
I guess it would be nice to be able to
like monitor a full sweep, huh? But the
thing is, you'd still need all the data
locally. Like most of the time you're
going to be running it. So you'd have to
be like pointing it at a remote server.
That sounds like a lot of work for
something that's going to be too
inconvenient to use for most people.
Uh, I will probably add like a single
file thingy arch.
I what I'll probably do is I'll
basically I'll probably just add a
wrapper that uploads all of your data
from runs to wand like just like
literally takes all of the data and
shoves it into wi
Um, there's not really a point in me
trying to switch to GLM because there's
not really any reasonable server of it
at the moment.
If Sarah Brass could get like reasonable
usage plans behind their stuff, it would
be awesome
without Python. No, it's all um it their
whole stack is Python [ __ ] man.
Like I'd be surprised if they have any
code that isn't Python at this point
Okay,
what else definitely needs to go? We
have checkpoint.h, which is this tiny
annoying thing.
Merging it all into a utils is way
worse.
Um I'm sick of dealing with Python.
It's the source of most of our bugs.
It's the source of most of our
performance issues and like users not
being able to use Puffer and it's also
the reason why a lot of our stuff is
like has to be poorly designed.
Honestly, like the CUDA to C barrier is
already bad enough the way that most
people write CUDA and C.
You definitely don't want multiple
language barriers. And in fact, even
different compilation units is bad.
Not until PyTorch is superseded. You
realize we don't use PyTorch here,
right? Like we have our own our own
trainer that is four to five times
faster than Torch and way more
numerically stable as well.
That was kind of the whole deal with
Puffer 4.
It's only about 4,000 lines of code and
it does everything that we need. It has
multiGPU,
has integration with all of our other
stuff,
and um it could be cleaner, but it's a
heck of a lot more readable than the
PyTorch source already. I'll tell you
that much.
Current PC setup, I have a miniITX box
that I built many years ago with a 3080
that is somehow still alive,
and I'm just using this for now while
I'm here.
I have a better setup in my main office
and uh on the farm.
it's just a bunch of like random file IO
and crap I think right
has all the kernels
here we have
this is our mining we have our mrew
kernels here. This is the entire This is
your inference path for Mingru. It's
very simple. Prefix scan's a little more
complicated to do fast for training.
This is why I say it's not as clean as
it could be.
There's this annoying recomputation
thing.
Here's your backwards pass from Ingrrew.
Again, a bit more complicated than I
would like, but not terrible terrible.
Um, we have all sorts of very nice
things in this setup though. We have
like contiguous memory weights,
contiguous memory gradients, single
kernel to apply model updates.
I'm not a big fan of this stupid thing
that we have here with all these init
functions and things. I think we can do
much better than this garbage like
pseudo polymorphism [ __ ] But I
mean, for what it is, it's pretty damn
good already.
Um, and it is genuinely like much more
numerically stable as well. BFlat 16
training works perfectly every time.
Watching US game tonight. Nah, I'm not
really uh I don't really watch sports.
The sports that I do myself are
incredibly boring to watch. So
that why you're so locked in? Not
really. I mean, I lit like literally
this is my second monitor at the moment.
This is not like super This is mostly
just like kind of thoughtful work.
I just have to figure out how I want
this to be structured for a couple of
days.
This is already a big improvement, but
there's still like
I'm trying to figure out how we get this
down to more compact. It's like the
puzzle pieces don't fit together
perfectly.
Timings in Discord. Thank you very much.
Cast fusion plus shared mem. So I'm
assuming that that cast operation that's
not a CPU uh optimization. That's just
like you fusing the
that's you fusing the GPU buffers for
GPU ends would be my assumption.
But then you do genuinely seem to get
quite a bit from shared me backward.
That's actually a very useful thing to
know. I do wonder if that makes uh if
that changes if that change does
anything on the main hardware target.
Yeah, I would like to read a PR for
that. Maybe not this second, but if you
put a PR up for that, I will at some
point go through it because that is like
that is the most important operation in
the pipeline.
is um optimized mint group.
All right. So, I mean we have like some
of these things that are kind of
standalone but not really. Like we got
this config loader,
we got this dashboard.
I guess selfplay and sweeps are kind of
awkward, right?
Maybe we can bleed some of the
big inlined kernels.
Can we bleed some of this from puffer
into like kernels here
and then bleed the launcher stuff into
this?
Does that make sense?
Stop learning to code any um I those
people are idiots. Just mute them and
move on.
Stop reading code. Yeah, you should
Yeah, you should just mute those people.
And also there's one other thing I want
to check.
Okay, we have a couple random [ __ ]
things.
Interesting.
And those are good optimizations, man.
If you can get the things cleaned up
into like testable mergeable things like
yeah by all means
I do expect that the CPU path can get
optimized quite a bit because I just I
refuse to believe that we're
bottlenecking on simulating breakout.
So there's probably like some like just
poorly done copy path somewhere.
What's it need? It shouldn't need [ __ ]
from loss.
buffer. Pie going to be refactored.
Yeah, that's already done, Arch. Well,
at least a draft of it's done. It's
crap.
So, this is what I wanted to figure out.
So, first of all, did it make this
longer?
Uh, I'm assuming that it just didn't
finish deleting stuff.
Where's advantage? 379 lines. Okay,
that's a decent chunk.
I think some of the optimizations in
there were premature. This was like
early stuff with Jonas
or Jonah. Um
single set of weights on all. So you
can't do that because the obs and action
spaces don't match.
That's the key problem.
If you came up with like a reasonable
way to train an encoding,
then sure.
Um, it's pretty obnoxious though.
The thing is like
it doesn't really matter that much
in some sense.
you kind of just don't need to train big
general models
um when you can sim really fast.
Huda occupancy max.
What is that?
Um, FPR, that's fine. You like
uh I'm pretty sure that CUDA's only it's
only deterministic
based on the GPU and the CUDA version
anyways. So, I don't think that that
weakens our determinism guarantee.
My guess would be that the issue that
you did that you had there is not that
you screwed up the learning, but if you
this is on your swept parameters.
There's a reason that we don't use like
50 mil. So you can get parameters that
solve in 50 mil, but only subject to
seed.
So you need to run it for a little bit
longer to make sure that you're getting
consistent solves across seeds.
If you try that, I think you'll see it
works.
If it doesn't, something's incredibly
sketchy. Okay.
Yeah, just don't break our determinism
is the main thing.
Like that's one of our best features.
And it's really obnoxious to tell when
you've broken it. I mean, I'm sure I'm
going to end up breaking it myself doing
all this jank, but at least I will be
able to fix it.
I guess this is
Yeah, this is inference path, huh?
Okay, this policy build crap is
obnoxious.
I think we have a bunch of redundancy in
here.
I'm not seeing anything other than the
logit stuff. Maybe.
Okay, there's a whole bunch of loading.
If I figure out a better way to do
policy,
do we consider cosine and kneeling part
of the optimizer?
I mean, that would be a good spot to
stick it to be fair.
The only big block of crap I see in here
is
logits.
I think that's an option that's not
going to save us. Like it's just moving
this tiny little bit of code and also
deleting this s this um standard library
usage.
Did we just get less code?
Oh, yay. Wait, no. 331.
Oh, yeah. 30 lines minus. Okay.
And selfplay 833. Okay. So, just minus a
little bit from this.
I don't have a good spot to stick sample
logits if I move that. I'm not sure I
want to yet either.
The pressure from selfplay is annoying.
I mean, that's was originally the reason
we did all of this here. I think we'll
get some ideas real quick. Um
I'll take a look in a second. I'm just
thinking
cuz the thing is it's like it's tied
into everything, right? It's this thing
that's very important, but it's only
used for a small fraction of the
environments
and it's just tied into everything.
4,000 lines of Python.
All right.
And just the bits
like this is 400, this is 800, this is
plus 1,200 lines of Python. Plus there's
some stuff in here. So let's say
plus,500 lines of Python
for just selfplay.
Doesn't that seem like ridiculously
excessive?
porting CUDA in between the running
test. Um, the thing is, man, like just
porting MS to CUDA on its own, like just
randomly is not super useful.
Um,
I guess on lower-end hardware with your
changes, it makes stuff much faster, but
I'm guessing that also they're probably
just some CPU side optimizations we
haven't done that would bridge a lot of
the gap and probably like the generic
mining group change is going to be the
most useful. Obviously, for ends that do
use GPU, we should use that GPU
optimization.
Um,
the thing is like it's not like every
end should just go to GPU, right? It's
going to end up being very specific
physics heavy or compute heavy ends
where you cannot reasonably get above a
million steps per core per second on
CPU.
Yeah. No, I know it's basically the
same.
I mean most of the time you just change
the um you know you just added change
the method to device and then you change
the math functions from the C library to
the CUDA library
the taste for architecture that's not
taste that's just being Bad.
Yeah. I whoever came up with that it's
like a genius marketing thing because it
takes it makes it seem like oh it's just
they're bad at the subject subjective
parts but it's really not that right.
It's not that it's um like just because
the tasks are hard to measure doesn't
mean that they're completely subjective.
Like the correct words are like bad,
stupid, dumb, useless.
Not just, oh, they have poor taste,
right? Like the latter, it just sounds
like, oh yeah, they're going to fix
that. That's just a minor alignment
issue. It's not. It's a huge skill
issue.
the big problem in my mind
is that you have this selfplay code
which really is only used for a small
chunk of ends. It's very important, but
it's not going to be used everywhere and
it's just cluttering.
It's cluttering everything. And there's
not really a reasonable way to separate
it. The only thing we can do is kind of
group it better.
Okay, first of all, the code is just
crap.
Oh, I'm sure it did, Jess.
We don't have um
we don't ever we have not ever had this
in C though.
Like there was some stuff you're doing
for instance with checkpointing where we
have the checkpointing already in this
in the CUDA optimized and um you know
you have access to it now because
there's no longer the barrier between
languages where you can't just easily
call Everything.
What am I doing? Welcome. This is I'm
working on the highest performance
reinforcement learning library.
Um,
currently that involves waiting through
a whole bunch of AI gen [ __ ] and
trying to get it into a state that is
remotely acceptable. We essentially we
had a bunch of stuff in Python that we
got to get rid of all the Python. It's
just bad at this point. We're trying to
get everything into CUD to C. It's way
too much code and I'm trying to like
pair it down a little bit at the moment.
If we keep all of the paths around, then
we no longer need to do any of this IO
loading stuff.
We could extend that into the sweep
architecture as well.
extra paths could be
dealt with.
What's the end goal?
Well, the end goal is to take the field
of reinforcement learning as a whole,
which has been sort of stagnated for
years, at least before Puffer, uh, make
the thing about 10,000 times faster,
which for the most part we have done,
make some major AR uh, innovations on
the architecture and algorithm, which
we've done, but there's still quite a
bit left to go, and simplify it
dramatically such that it's relatively
easy to apply to new problems, which
we've made a lot of progress on, but
there's still some room to go. So at
this stage,
I think it's mostly we need better
performance for our current algorithm.
We need a much cleaner code path than we
have at the moment. And then there's
maybe a few last research questions that
we need to answer
um before we can start reliably chucking
this on like really hard unsolved
problems and just having it solve out of
the box. We're at the point we're pretty
much within like a few days of like
semi-skilled work, you can set
state-of-the-art on most like most RL
problems out there. Um, even ones that
have had concerted effort behind them,
but there are still a few issues
overall.
Yeah, this is RL not for language
models. We train tiny superhuman models.
Uh, we a lot of our research tasks are
games. Turns out games are a really good
task for research, but they can do much
more than that. Games are just nice and
interpretable, so they're good
benchmarks.
It's pretty unintuitive what tasks are
challenging or not in RL, frankly, if
you're not used to it.
I don't see any reason that we need to
checkpoint more frequently than the
snapshot interval.
there. Anything else we can save with
this?
I think that's fine to start
environments that train agents on
specialized tasks.
Wait, what do you mean RL environments
that train agents on specialized tasks?
If that's for LM stuff, I have no idea.
But like that's kind of the entirety of
what we do here is we train our L agents
on specialized tasks. So our goal is not
to improve general capabilities. It is
to solve the specialized tasks.
Yeah, but that was kind of like just
train on a bunch of really complicated
tasks, Jess.
I mean, what would it look like? So,
it's kind of difficult to the thing is
it might be kind of difficult to imagine
how the hell you scale RL up to general
intelligence like that. But it's also
really difficult to imagine how the hell
you scale intelligence up from GPT1,
right? Like
people can say, "Oh yeah, this will
scale." But nobody [ __ ] saw it.
They hoped and they happened to be right
for like a decent chunk of their
assumptions.
Um but there was just no reasonable way
to predict the extent to which stuff
would scale.
Similarly with RL like what would have
happened if we had gotten
I mean what would even be reasonable
trillion step per second training. I
think that's actually pretty reasonable
with smallish policies on a thousand
GPUs. Yeah. Yeah. So, what if you got
trillion step per second training on
like a full scale? Like, think of like
the most ambitious game type project
ever, but it's essentially just meant to
have tons and tons and tons of different
stuff to do. Not like designed for
people necessarily.
Just like the biggest virtual world
project ever.
I mean, what's the most that's ever been
spent on on an MMO?
I think it's like most gamedev, big
gamedev budgets are in the hundreds of
millions of dollars.
All right, so the labs have spent tens
to hundreds of billions at this point.
And so what would happen if you just
tossed $5 billion at uh development of
and I don't even think you'd need that
much, but what if you tossed $5 billion
at the development of a really big
virtual world and you made it super
fast,
used like '90s style gamedev techniques,
and uh you scale training to a trillion
steps per second.
War Fortress would be very cool.
I have no idea how fast that envirs
Get the guy roller coaster tycoon.
I don't think we would quite go to like
write stuff in assembly. more like
very minimal game engine and C using
'90s MMO development principles.
The whole thing would probably be on a
tile grid of some sort.
Um or at the very least it would like
just be animation smoothing and making
very coarse movements.
Yeah, I have no idea why that guy did it
that way. He probably just did it that
way cuz he could.
vision models needing a certain size.
It's just sad.
No.
Yeah. Um to be fair
like domain specific vision models
probably can just be a few million
parameters.
We have decentish stuff like uh with
just a few cons
but at our current scale that already
that like cuts perf by a factor of 10.
So it's just not super worth it.
it. If anybody wants to try to get like
a decent vision encoder just as fast as
possible, by all means, go ahead. I
mean, that would be an amazing
contribution to Puffer. But I I think
that it's probably just going to hard
bottleneck by a factor of 10 just like
straight up based on the number of bytes
in the input.
I guess you could get maybe like a 64x
64 render. Uh, even that is rough
and that just doesn't give you a lot of
information.
I mean, you can kind of just do the
napkin math of the amount of data that
goes through the system with like 128x
128 images at 10 mil SPS.
It's It's a lot.
like yeah what is the minimal encoder
representation for different data
formats is the precise form of
I mean, if it's a frozen encoder,
potentially
it would help if it were a frozen
encoder, to be fair.
Maybe Jess.
I think that'll just become more obvious
as we solve more hard ends though.
Like we're actually not like pixels are
not my top concern. Even
solving pixels solves maybe like 20% of
the obs issue.
Right? So the problem with looking at
vision is compression in that way.
Right? is we actually don't care about
representing the entire
we don't care about the full
representation of the image, right? We
only care about extracting the portions
that are in like useful for behavior.
That's why arguably a compression
objective is not ideal for RL.
Compression objectives force you to much
larger models than are required for
policies.
It's a subtle point, but an important
one. Right.
Okay. So,
it's also it's one of the reasons that
RL policies get to be so small.
There's just a lot of stuff they don't
have to care about modeling.
this looks like a miserable way to spend
the next hour. What do you all think?
Yeah, that looks pretty uh pretty
miserable.
I guess it would be this plus what is
it?
It'd be this plus this, which is even
worse.
Well, let's see if there's anything else
that we uh we can work on first.
So, we know we have to tackle this whole
selfplay sweep mess. Probably it's going
to result in shortening a whole bunch of
this code, merging some of this into
there, and then some of it into puffer.
What other files definitely need to die?
No, we don't convince ourselves that all
these files are fine.
There definitely at least a few of these
we don't need.
I think that is the best way to spend a
time though. Whatever. I like suffering.
We will suffer a little bit. Um, but I
deserve a couple minute break here. Let
me get up, use the restroom, walk around
a little bit, grab a drink, and then I
will be right back
and we will work on this. All right, see
you in a few.
Oh, yeah. Star Puffer on GitHub if you
haven't already. It helps me out a lot.
I think I remember that being a stupid
thing that got by.
Which frozen checkpoint each bank is
using
See, this is just a thing that
apparently Codeex randomly did and got
by me. That's completely [ __ ] wrong,
completely and utterly stupid.
I'm streaming another 45 minutes as well
today. Seems reasonable. Little short
little 4 hour uh 4 hour stream.
This type of work is very obnoxious. I
really don't have um I mean I did a
couple hours of it before stream this
morning and about 6 hours of this in a
day is the most I can handle otherwise
like that's the most that is my uh my
tolerance for [ __ ] let's Okay,
vision observations into buffer.
Um,
well, the endgame for good vision
observations would be that a client
really wants them.
So, we put the effort in to come up with
a relatively efficient policy that
doesn't completely bottleneck training.
We get vision to like I don't know a
million steps per second
on um a reasonable model size and then
we scale it
probably something like that
Well, because like
there's very little research on making
anything insanely fast. Um, basically
any individual component of puffer on
its own doesn't do anything for the
field. Like if we just took our trainer
for instance or like our model
architecture or whatever and we plug it
into any other RL library, their stuff
will bottleneck it so hard that you'll
see zero advantage from any of our
improvements.
That's why we had to redo everything
whole stack.
Yeah, I know that there are like
production vision things where they
would be very happy to get one image per
second.
It's kind of sad.
I could believe that
with like not a crazy policy arch.
That would still be pretty good though,
Casper.
Actually, if you were um
Well,
I guess one project if you were
interested in doing it would be you
could take the uh the procgen
environment which has they have like all
this dated Python code that barely runs
anymore, but the source is C++ so you
could probably just port or autoport
even procgen.
um change the texture pack to get 64x 64
obs and get it into puffer at like over
a mill SPS. That would actually be very
nice to have procgen at reasonable
speeds.
That'd be pretty cool.
I think at those speeds with a proper
per hyper pram sweep you just full solve
instantly.
We do have a KDNN bind for cons. It just
wasn't that fast. DNN is also kind of
jank in the way it works.
We are less strict on environment
bindings, Casper. Um,
yeah, we're less strict on environment
bindings as long as they're correct.
It's mostly the puffer core code that
we're super strict about.
So, you could probably just stick all
that into the bindings.
like the crafter craft axe net hack
binds
um all the runes escape stuff it's a lot
of it is like AI craft crap at least by
people who have some idea what they're
doing and aren't just like noobs vibe
coding stuff but are just very heavily
they're at least like giving reasonable
instructions at a systems level rather
than a feature level. Um obviously not
good for core. You see me doing that
with core here but then taking literal
weeks to edit stuff manually and get
everything clean. Um, but the end of
binding since they're purely horizontal,
right? And like end of binding being bad
doesn't screw up puffer core at all,
we're less strict on it.
Pirate software type. I never actually
watched any of that guy's stuff. I don't
know if his stuff was good or not or
bad. I don't know.
Actually, funny enough, I watched some
of Primagen stuff when I was first doing
systems.
He has some good takes on stuff. He just
gets nerd sniped by every new shiny
thing.
But he's kind of made himself a job out
of just doing that on repeat now, hasn't
he?
Infinite magic numbers.
Uh, so fun thing, I actually I don't
think that that is bad. If you're hard
coding constants that are only used once
and just like not splitting stuff up and
doing it top to bottom, that's actually
totally fine.
If you look up, I'm actually happy with
this code. This is neural MMO 3. It's
3,000 lines. It's all in one file.
This is the core step function.
I guarantee you if you tried to like
split this up and whatever, you'd end up
making it way longer.
It's really simple to do this as well.
It should almost be default. It's like
you make a new function when you would
have to copy paste code otherwise. You
don't make a new function just to make a
new function. You default to write it
top to bottom. You default to use the
simplest data structure possible to
accomplish your task, right?
So we're minus 1,000 lines of code today
for the same features or same meaningful
features.
Minus 1,000 lines of code in a day is
not bad.
We probably do need the evict thing on
selfplay, huh?
Well, I mean, I'm not even going to
bother.
See, but crash the thing is like doing
stuff in the shortest, simplest way
possible. That is the nice thing.
All the like, oh, I want to come up with
pretty abstractions that scale. That's
just Google Nerd Snipe [ __ ]
Like
for the most part, you don't make nice
building blocks for other people to use
because their blocks aren't the same
shape as yours.
Oh, that's just straight troll. Yeah,
the functional people are just straight
troll.
You have to at least drop the uh
immutable memory [ __ ] before you can
even have a conversation about other
stuff from there.
Sometimes the most maintainable thing is
this is short and easy to rewrite if the
requirements change
like the ab the highly abstracted thing
is almost always harder to rewrite
if uh you guess wrong.
The whole error handling thing is also
incredibly dumb. like
for most applications
um
like when an error is this should never
happen and there's no way to continue if
it does you don't want to pass it back
up the stack like you want it to just
the code to die and print a stack trace
right there
really simple stuff and you'd be
surprised how much code that saves This
Oh, it still adds fallbacks for
everything. You have to yell at it to
get it to not do that.
One of the funniest things in my opinion
is like um
like people say Google's core advantage
is oh you know they have all of their
own code to train the AI on. It's like
are you sure you want to train uh your
AI on that? Really?
Some of my code.
At least the pieces that I've actually
been able to put some time into are
good.
if they have high quality code. That's
the joke crit. They kind of don't.
I'm sure there are like five guys that
don't ever leave their like basement
office at Google that actually write all
the good stuff, but uh the average dev
is like yikes.
None of the big tech companies have like
good devs on average. Not a single damn
one of them.
It's kind of one of the unfortunate
things like honestly about um like
actually giving a [ __ ] about the quality
of your work. You basically can't work
at any of the big tech companies. At
least not unless you're going to a
specific high talent team because you'll
just be miserable.
Just the quality of stuff is awful.
See the thing is the hiring bar is like
it's completely decorrelated from
actually knowing what you're doing.
It's not a high bar, right? In the sense
it's not like you have to be a good
programmer. It's you have to have spent
a lot of your time studying really dumb
and arbitrary puzzles
that have nothing to do with your
day-to-day or like writing good code or
building good systems or like anything
at all. It's just stupid lead Good.
have to pay you to work full-time on
improving Microsoft Teams for a year.
It would have to be at least like 50
mil. I don't even [ __ ] know. It would
basically have to be like, "All right, I
got enough puffer funding to do whatever
I want for a decade
since it would go into a business
investment, it wouldn't just immediately
get hit by personal income tax. I'm
pretty sure that's how that works.
So would yeah 50 million uh funding
would be plenty for all the stuff I'd
want to
This, I would believe, needs to be a few
hundred lines.
Gross.
I don't even know what this does. This
is just
what? This is just wild true, isn't it?
I don't even know why. I don't even I
didn't even think this was valid.
Oh, actually, wait. Doesn't this I think
this does show up in like KN&NR, doesn't
it? I I don't even know what that does.
I'm assuming that's while true.
or nothing.
Nothing. Nothing. Like
I I don't even the [ __ ]
Okay.
And we'll have like 10 minutes to
actually look and see if there's
anything I can see to fix.
Don't really need the anchor thing.
We will.
Let's see. 15 minutes to get under 13K
lines. What do y'all think?
Does it need to compile? What?
Yes, it needs to compile. Of course, we
need to be able to train break out under
13K having not totally broken
everything.
Hey, bet
work's going well. Actually, the uh the
need for selfplay is what triggered the
um the early refactors here.
There's definitely stuff we can get
here.
DM's wanting a code review.
Oh, is this the explosion? Like the
chain reaction out of it looked cool.
We'll get to it shortly.
Not today, of course. Today, I have
spent six hours
refactoring this mess, hence the title.
That help
barely.
Okay. Actually, the thing at the bottom
is
sort of fine.
Well, wait. You should do um the obvious
thing to include, right, if you don't
want to have to deal with full selfplay
is train versus the scripted bot. Duh,
right?
Upper li acquired. What?
Have any acquisition offer for puffer?
No. And we're not really looking to get
it acquired either. That's not the uh
the intent here.
Like puffer liib first of all puffer lib
is the open source library. If anything
we would be spinning out application
companies on different problems we can
solve with RL and then trying to get
those subsidiaries acquired.
Like all our core stuff is just free
open source software. And in fact, the
company is specifically structured to
make it easier to uh like keep doing all
the open source stuff.
We also there's like again making that
core company public even if we could do
that sounds horrible. Why would we do
that?
I have no idea what the hell that mess
even is. Bet.
Like I have no idea who the hell's using
that crap.
So also this thing is uh highly
redundant I would think as well.
I mean we're not going to get today to
like mess with this full thing. I just
want to cut 50 lines and call today
under 13K.
Wait, why does it need to write for
this?
Oh, the score. Sure.
Bit by bit all the code just disappears.
It's kind of funny.
Why do you want procgen? Is a specific
thing or is it nice to have? Um, so
Proctorgen is historically one of the
better ends released. Like Atari and
Proctgen are the two that would be nice.
I think Atari does have a RAM version.
Possibly Proctctor has a RAM version as
well. I don't know. I actually don't
know how they do it. You could probably
expose the RAM though. Um or like some
OBS from it. It just it's a nice suite
of ends and we kind of don't have any
reasonable third party ends that we can
compare against anybody else's stuff cuz
everybody else's Ms are so slow. So, it
would be good to have them. And it also
it's like you bind one set of uh you do
one binding and you get access to 16 M's
is pretty good.
LI in the RL second place. I knew there
was like a sixth place or something.
Somebody the second place also got it.
That's cool.
That's very cool.
I think we'll end there for today. Okay,
there's no point in just trying to get
it under 26 uh 26 more lines today. I
will push this though, as long as
breakout works.
We'll do a quick count of some stuff as
well.
Do you want ported to see your bindings
with the C++?
Um, if it's much easier to leave the
C++, you can leave the C++ if it's
easier to bind. As long as it's fast,
I suspect that like the per end code is
pretty simple, though. Like I honestly
I'd be surprised if you couldn't just
autoport everything and just like
confirm that the same actions produce
the same result.
I mean, I guess it also depends on
whether the original C++ code is good or
not. I haven't read it.
If the original C++ code is actually
good, then like yeah, just leave that
instead of putting some like shitty
codeex Start.
All right.
So, check this out.
This is the current version. We started
with like 10 more files than this and
1.2K lines more code than this.
So, we cut quite a bit today.
Um,
I think if we're going to like let's be
fair about how we were tabulating this.
So,
I'm going to say there's 1.5k lines that
were from
selfplay.
There's some in here as well. So, 1.5k
lines from selfplay.
1.5k from constellation. So that's 3,000
lines.
This is uh this is nothing. So this is
1,700.
5500.
Anything else?
Did I do that right? It's at least 5700
lines of this though, right? So then
that takes us down if we're like doing
the equivalents. This is like 7ishk.
Oh no, but there's also Hang on, hang
on, hang on. We got to do this properly.
So
let's add this up.
3.7K
Yeah, it's like 5,500 lines or
something. So, we're only at like 7kish
lines here.
It's not terrible
over the original. I mean,
there's still definitely some we can
cut,
but like at the very least, like
constellation and protein and stuff, we
shouldn't count in that.
All right.
We still want to cut like another
thousand or 2,000 lines, I'd say, to
have this clean before the release
and a few files.
Um, I'm tired. Uh, this is a short day,
but this type of work is just incredibly
like obnoxious.
I can only really do this for so many
hours. So,
we do make progress though. This is good
progress on release.
Uh, thank you folks for tuning in.
I will be streaming more of this. So, if
you're new around here, puffer.ai, it's
all open source. Click the fish. Or
actually, don't click the fish. is not a
link. Click the star here. Star GitHub
helps a lot. And join us on Discord to
get involved with dev. You can follow me
on X for more RL content.